there's a four blind men and an elephant
problem when arguing against
intersectional lunacy that's a good way
of putting it and I seem to be arguing
with each of them over different aspects
of the movement is there a good one good
way to unify and help them see the whole
animal that's a that's a good question
you know one of the things that I tend
to do is going to the source material
which is why I was quoting from the
actual black lives matter page today
that and you know it's changing it used
to have some differently egregious stuff
that's that's gone now but pointing out
what is actually there and the
inconsistencies within it is hard to
totally evade if the people that you're
talking away they're in anyway good
faith it's hard to totally evade that's
an incomplete answer though by a lot
yeah I mean I think the problem is we
all swim upstream to greater and lesser
effect because the people that we are
talking to our actively resisting
comprehension if they were even a little
bit inclined to comprehend which they've
been trained out of by all of these
Kafka traps they would see it because
it's obvious yeah they're pulling down
statues of whom right there vandalizing
Stevie Ray Vaughan statues in Austin oh
that doesn't sound very reasonable to me
at George Washington really yeah yeah
okay I'm aware that he was a slave owner
but you know he also it was an important
force and you know far-sighted for his
era but you know the use of the word but
in the last sentence is what makes you a
racist right and but I know he was a
slave owner but right but I do know he
was a slave owner but I mean you know
Conrad Lorentz an important person in
our field
you know what behavior yeah he was a
member of the Nazi Party all right am I
going to pretend actually know that yeah
well he regretted it later in his life
but it's certainly a fact yeah you know
in George Washington was not a family
Agassiz the you know first director of
the Museum at Harvard was I think a
bigot an anti-semite yeah
and our a Fisher was an anti-semite um
you know here's the crazy one you know
Lindbergh thought we should support
Hitler and that does not invalidate his
crossing of the Atlantic right
so anyway history is complex and the
idea that you're gonna pull down these
statues why are you pulling down the
statues because it shows that you can
its power yeah it feels good in the
moment that's locked down for three
months and this feel is empowering yeah
and you can't go to bars well I don't
you know it proves it proves what this
thing is if you can pull down a statue
of George Washington on video and not go
to jail
right what have you just shown you've
shown your boss we get it
[Music]